vous voilà réveiller pour partir à
l'aventuré un parcours à faire pour
sauver les bouées au pays d'amélie une
petite fille chasseur de bruits le matin
comme tous les matins elle allait vers
son bol de chocolat chaud quand un gros
bruit même un énorme bruit a dévoré tous
les bruits de la ville bien sûr avant
que ça se produise il y avait dans cette
ville plein de petits bruits des gros
bruits des bruits d'où des bruits
méchant donc elle a décidé de partir à
la chasse aux bruits pour récupérer tous
ces sons qui donne de la couleur de
l'eau d'heure de l'effervescence
et du bonheur dans la vie mais il y a
quinze ans l'exposition comporte 11
modules à hauteur d'enfants touchés vue
oui tous les sens sont mobilisés le
voyage d'amélie est une exposition qu'on
peut toucher et pas seulement avec les
yeux c'est un moyen bien sûr de leur
permettre d'être à l'écouté faire
attention un petit peu ce qui se passe
autour d'eux et là d'une manière plus
sensible de regarder d'écouter de voir
de toucher et de vivre une expérience
sensorielle ce un camaïeu de tissus de
couleurs qu'on peut trouver dans le ciel
avec des textures différentes
donc là on est sur le toucher un petit
peu plus loin on a aussi des des galets
sur la plage donc là l'idée c'est
d'apprendre quelques notions de rythme
destiné aux enfants de 6 mois à 6 ans
l'exposition sensorielle vous emmène en
voyage celui de la petite amélie à vous
de vous glisser dans ses pas